[Music]  the new gatsby movie i don't know if  you've seen it it's in 3d yeah 3d yeah  great gatsby in 3d yeah i understand why  uh i understand why action or science  fiction movies should be in 3d  but why the great gatsby okay i watched  the movie and you can kind of tell that  the director was a little desperate to  come up with 3d moments  for the great gatsby yeah take a look  i've gotten all these things where i've  gotten all these things for her now she  just  she just wants to run away  she wants to leave that  jay  would anyone like a drink  what kind of a row  you trying to cause in my house anyhow  he isn't causing me while you're causing  me  please have a little self-control  self-control  oh i suppose the latest thing  the idea  of every decision  of course if anything is not your liking  i'll change it  [Applause]  i could watch that  i could watch that all night  i'm like a cat